[Music]  My dear Belle your soul ahead of your  time this is a small village you are the  worst  gorgeous thing I've ever seen nobody  deserves and it's small-minded as well  but small also means safe  I've come for my father Cullens the  light  look a girl who said that  ello you can talk hello course it's all  the other does how lovely to make your  acquaintance  what does he do a true what happens from  the last petal for the last hour we're  men's are beasts forever and we become a  loose  what is he doing get out of here  you have to help me you have to stand if  she is the one or break the spell you  must finally learn to love so duster  have you really read every one of these  books somewhere in Greek who as it can  be  rising in  yummy  [Music]